bonjour à tous La séance est ouverte sur
LCP 9 novembre 2022 ce jour-là
l'Assemblée nationale auditionne un
ancien Premier ministre il s'agit de
Jean Castex futur président de la RATP
il a été nommé par Emmanuel Macron et
c'est une nomination dite article 13 de
la Constitution c'est à dire qu'elle est
soumise à l'approbation des 3/5 des
commissions du Parlement la parole est
agent Castex mesdames et messieurs
députés depuis
ma venue devant vous c'était à la fin du
mois de juillet il s'est produit un
élément nouveau totalement imprévisible
à l'époque qui est la démission de la
présidente directrice générale de la
RATP un exercice Catherine Guillouard
que je voudrais comme je l'ai fait hier
devant le Sénat d'emblée devant vous
saluer à la fois pour le bilan et
l'action qui ont été les siens à la tête
de cette grande entreprise publique
pendant 5 ans
le aura sans doute l'occasion d'y
revenir aussi peut-être pour les raisons
évidemment qu'il ne m'appartient en rien
de commenter puisqu'elles sont d'ordre
personnel et familial qui l'ont conduit
à prendre cette décision mais voilà je
voulais quand même lui rendre hommage et
en tout cas vous rappeler qu'évidemment
cette circonstance n'était pas du tout
prévue n'était pas attendu
lorsque m'a été proposé à l'époque la
présence de l'Agence de financement des
infrastructures transport personne
n'imaginait que la RATP se trouverait
vacances bon cet élément est intervenu
et de fait depuis le premier octobre
dernier donc depuis quelques semaines
Guillouard a cessé ses fonctions et
c'est dans ce contexte que en effet
monsieur le Président était proposé de
me porter candidat à cette fonction ce
que je vous le dis d'emblée j'ai fait
sans hésiter
non je pense que nous allons y revenir
que je sous-estime la charge des
difficultés que le poste en question le
rapporteur les a brièvement mentionnés
qui qui m'attendent le président futur
quel qu'il soit derrière RATP mais vous
ne serez peut-être pas surpris en tout
cas pour celles et ceux qui me
connaissent un peu mieux que c'est pas
de nature à me m’arrêter j'ai dit je
vous le rappelle lorsque j'ai quitté mes
fonctions à l'Hôtel Matignon et que j'ai
passé le relais à Madame Elisabeth borne
que je sortais du champ politique mais
que je souhaitais continuer à me rendre
utile pour la nation alors
non pas que j'étais
inutile j'espère à la tête de l'Agence
de financement des infrastructures de
transport mais disons que les enjeux ne
sont pas les mêmes et comme je le
rappelais d'abord la présidence de
l'agence financement des infrastructures
de transport est un poste non exécutif
il y a une déléguée générale alors que
ce dont nous allons parler ce matin
c'est un poste exécutif opérationnel on
va dire à part entière et puis surtout
s'il fallait donner une différence on va
dire manifeste la fifte comprend en tout
et pour tout 5 salariés et il y en a un
peu plus de 70 000 à la RATP donc je
pense que vous mesurez avec moi la
différence en termes d'enjeux bon donc
disait je n'ai pas hésité parce que
d'abord je l'indiquais il y a un
contexte on va y revenir j'imagine
longuement ce matin difficile
il y a des défis nombreux
et que je pense
qu'il faut quelqu'un d'expérimenter je
le revendique d'emblée devant la
commission et il y a une vision
politique
au sens global du terme pour tenter de
les affronter
la RATP bon c'est une je le dis pour
vous tous
c'est une très belle maison
très belle très beau symbole de notre
pays de notre patrimoine qui va et qui
fait des transports évidemment vous le
savez maintenant au-delà l'Île-de-France
présente dans de dans plusieurs régions
d'abord et dans de nombreux pays
capitale du monde d'ailleurs se
développe c'est un fer de lance il faut
le voir comme ça cette diversification
du savoir-faire français même si nous
aurons là aussi sans doute que m'a
reparler peut-être faut-il
recentrer un peu sur des objectifs
prioritaires cette politique de
filialisation et de diversification sans
jamais oublier
le cœur de métier
je n'oublie pas que les métiers qui s'y
exercent qui sont nombreux je crois
qu'il y a ma 174
sont des métiers parfois très difficile
parfois très difficile
confronté à des situations compliquées
je n'oublie pas non plus alors que je
m'occupais avant d'être Premier ministre
de de la mission sur le déconfinement
nous sommes au printemps 2020
que on a on n'a pas fermé
les transports publics les salariés de
la RATP
sont restés sur le sur le pont je vous
rappelle aussi peut-être dans
souvenez-vous ces lignes de bus dédiées
qui en fonctionnait au bénéfice du
personnel soignant pour les amener pour
les conduire au plus fort de la crise et
en particulier au moment où
l'Île-de-France notamment était
confronté
au premier pic épidémique pour amener
donc les les soignants sur leur lieu de
travail
mais vous avez dit il y a une situation
actuelle qui se trouve au carrefour de
très nombreux défis de très nombreux
enjeux dont je vous le dis tout de suite
gélatine conviction que la RATP
est de taille allait surmonter mais
évidemment il va falloir que
collectivement nous nous donnions les
moyens alors à partir des questions que
vous m'avez posez mais c'est un porteur
et puis celles qui viendront je voudrais
rappeler
ces défis mais bon il y en a d'abord de
très court terme très court terme je
suis auditionné aujourd'hui c'est fixé
depuis un certain temps monsieur le
Président la veille d'un mouvement
social extrêmement important demain
il va affecter le fonctionnement du
service mouvement social lui-même décidé
le deuxième
appel à la grève qui avait été fait dans
ce cadre il y a un certain temps enfin
bon qui illustre les problématiques qui
nous réunissent ce matin
la première évidemment
m'adressant aux usagers précisément
c'est celle de la qualité de la
continuité du service vous avez parlé
tout le monde le voit les usagers le
ressentent elle est particulièrement
importante elles sont particulièrement
importantes ces difficultés sur le
réseau bus ou au mois d'octobre qui
vient à peine de se terminer
25% de l'offre n'a pas pu être réalisé
avec tout ce que ça entraîne de fil
d'attente de difficultés de tous ordres
pour pour les usagers vous avez vu lu
peut-être subi vous-même le fait que
dans le métro en tout cas sur un certain
nombre de lignes il y a aujourd'hui
des difficultés
vous avez vu aussi sans doute l'origine
de ces difficultés liées à des
disponibilités on va dire de personnel
soit que la RATP des problèmes pour
recruter soit qu'il y ait un taux
d'absentéisme plus élevé qu'à
l'accoutumée bon évidemment ça sera si
vous m'accordez votre confiance
évidemment l'un des sujets dont je vais
m'emparer immédiatement dans la mesure
où il impacte la vie quotidienne de
millions de nos concitoyens franciliens
bien sûr mais aussi visiteur touristes
etc bon c'est l'urgence absolue comme je
l'ai fait au Sénat je voudrais rappeler
mais je n'ai pas besoin de le faire mais
le dire quand même devant les repentants
de la nation que vous êtes et qui
vivaient dans vos circonscriptions que
quand même
s'il n'y avait que la RATP qui avait des
problèmes pour recruter ça se saurait je
dis ça parce que tout le monde tombe à
bras raccourcis là sur la RATP
je pense j'ai regardé évidemment les
mesures qui ont été prises qu'elle a
fait ses meilleures efforts
Île-de-France mobilité j'en profite pour
le dire aussi de son côté et il faut ce
qu'il faut faire je l'ai dit de devant
vos colocataires je le redis j'ai
évidemment une des premières personnes
que j'ai appelé c'est Madame Pécresse je
ce sera une des toutes premières
personnes que je rencontre ré si vous
validiez ma nomination il faut très vite
je crois qu'il faut trouver des
solutions mettre en oeuvre celle qui
agissent en trouver le cas échéant de
nouvelles autour de la table de manière
consensuelle l'usager savoir si ça
relève digne de France mobilité du
niveau de l'offre si le niveau de
l'offre a été pourvu ou pas et donc ça
relève de responsabilité de la RATP pour
lui
pardonnez-moi c'est un peu indifférent
et rien ne serait pire en tout cas que
de dire on se renvoie là-bas non les
responsabilités nous devons les assumer
ensemble et un des engagements que je
prends en tout cas des volontiers qui
est la mienne si je suis nommé c'est
évidemment de tout faire pour que avec
l'autorité organisatrice
que vous connaissez bien les relations
soit les plus fluides possibles et la
recherche de solution
partagée de façon à répondre à ce
problème immédiat
le deuxième élément le premier rappel
comme je l'ai dit aussi que finalement
la RATP mesdames et je suis député mais
pas unile c'est problème de recrutement
elle les suivit la différence c'est que
ça se voit peut-être encore plus vite
qu'ailleurs je te parle en termes de
conséquence mais elle n'est pas non plus
une île pour ou par rapport à tous les
phénomènes conjoncturels que vous
traitez d'ailleurs dans cette hémicycle
d'abord la facture énergétique appelle
RATP la facture énergétique de la RATP
la RATP consomme 2,5 Tera wattheure par
an d’énergie considérable c'est elle
seule 2% de la consommation énergétique
d’île-de-france bon ben vous avez une
facture électrique
2021210 millions d'euros cette année
elle n'est pas finie mais autour de 265
et l'année prochaine alors ça va
dépendre des sciences du gouvernement
des votes du législateur etc mais enfin
les chiffrages puisque le budget 20 est
en cours de préparation pourrait aussi
aller entre 480 550 millions d'euros
voilà voilà des choses très concrètes
vis-à-vis desquelles il va falloir
se positionner vite et voir avec
l'autorité avec l'autorité organisatrice
avec l'État évidemment quelle solution
peuvent être trouvées de la même façon
c'est tensions inflationnistes on
revient d'ailleurs au conflit social de
demain ont-elles des incidences sur les
questions de négociation salariale
et là encore je rappelle où je porte à
la connaissance de votre commission que
la RATP cela houlette de Catherine Ward
n'est pas resté sans agir il y a eu un
dialogue social à profondique a été
conduit qui a qui a mené à différentes
revalorisations des rémunérations c'est
bien que les distribunération à la RATP
déjà depuis le début de l'année 2022 en
cours ont progressé de 5,2%
et je constate je le dis dans la
commission avec satisfaction qu'un
effort tout particulier a été fait à la
fois sur les basses salaires et sur les
métiers les plus difficiles je pense en
particulier à la revalorisation des
primes de nuit qui a été acté dans le
cadre d'un acte d'un accord avec les
organisations syndicales je crois au
moins d'avril dernier bon mais voilà des
sujets très concrets immédiat sur
lesquels il va falloir agir et j'ai déjà
dans le prolongement de ce qui était
fait indiquer que la fameuse Nao
obligatoire sur les rémunérations pour
2023 dans le train suivant devrait être
anticipé compte tenu des évolutions de
l'inflation et s'engager dans les jours
on va dire qui suivent ma prise de
fonction SI prise de fonction il y a
alors ça c'est voilà c'est les enjeux
immédiats sur lesquels évidemment je
vais m'impliquer beaucoup
et mais évidemment il y en a bien
d'autres cas cité leur apporteur qui
paraît à horizon un peu plus lointains
aujourd'hui bien entendu bon occasion
d'y revenir les Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques j'y ajouterai si vous
permettez même si c'est d'ampleur moins
de la Coupe du monde de rugby en 2023
voilà je ne l'oublie pas personne ici je
pense peut imaginer une seconde que je
l'oublie
j'ai lu avec attention tout ce qui s'est
passé au Stade de France il y a quelques
semaines donc il faut que nous en
tirions toutes les conséquences de
manière évidemment partenariale RATP
n'est pas le seul acteur m'a fait je le
dis pour les Jeux Olympiques et
Paralympiques on attend certains jours
un million de visiteurs enfin d'usagers
supplémentaire dans les transports
derrière ça il y a aussi je lisais les
Jeux Olympiques aussi un potentiel de
modernisation c'est à dire tous nos
systèmes biéthiques de réservation etc
il y a des gros problèmes d'amélioration
de modernisation qu'il faut accélérer la
faveur des jeux avec l'idée par exemple
que de façon numérique c'est l'objectif
40 % des billets pris par les fameux
visiteurs dont je viens de parler
puissent l'être de façon dématérialisée
bon donc voyez il y a on dit ça mais on
pourrait en parler longtemps et vous
avez raison que je retrouve en fait
monsieur le rapporteur un sujet que
j'avais très largement exploré lorsque
j'étais délégué interministériel il y a
le sujet évidemment majeur de
l'ouverture à la concurrence
évidemment majeur bon qui a commencé je
le rappelle pour tout le monde sauf
qu'il a commencé pour l'instant dans un
périmètre qui n'est pas le périmètre
historique de la RATP je rappelle le
réseau Optile la grande couronne pour
faire simple ou la RATP était déjà un
peu présente
et où elle a répondu à un certain nombre
d'appels d'offres organisées par
Île-de-France mobilité bon
mais évidemment la grande échéance pour
la RATP c'est son réseau historique de
bus d'abord échéance 1er janvier 2025
ensuite vous le savez viendront le tram
et le métro
là dessus évidemment s'inquiète
alors il peut avoir des des grands
débats sur le principe même de
l'ouverture à la concurrence bon ça je
veux dire le législateur à trancher bon
mais tout est dans l'art d'exécution
comme d'habitude au-delà des principes
il y a des modalités et ce que je
constate
c'est que le compte n'y est pas tout à
fait d'abord parce qu'il y a encore des
textes qui doivent être pris ou adaptés
et ensuite parce que au-delà de l'aspect
normatif et juridique qui a bien entendu
tout le cadre et d'abord le cadre social
bon il y a un bon point je vous donne
mon point de vue qui était celui de
l'ancien Premier ministre puisque c'est
un sujet qui n'est pas nouveau qui
s'appelle le cadre social territorialisé
alors à la fois il suicide des
inquiétudes qu'est-ce qu'il y a dedans
mais au moins il a un objectif qui est
bon qui est de mettre tout le monde à
armes égales parce que sinon si la
concurrence se fait avec des droits
sociaux inégaux le risque soyons clair
c'est le dumping
et que les parts de marché soient
gagnées par les moins 10 ans sociaux et
ça il faut à tout prix l'éviter alors la
RATP depuis 2016
se prépare cette ouverture à congrange
elle s'est réorganisée elle a
déjà négocié un certain nombre de sujets
mais ce cadre social par exemple malgré
tous les heures et les heures de
négociation n'a pas débouché sur un
accord
ce qui a conduit après décesseur à
prendre soin pas une mesure unilatérale
qui a été contestée par certaines
organisations syndicales
le juge a désigné une médiation qui est
en cours
et donc voilà ce que va trouver le
nouveau président et il faudra reprendre
le chemin de la négociation dans le
cadre de cette médiation pour essayer
d'aboutir de clarifier de rassurer
c'est un point évidemment essentiel le
futur président de la RATP se retrouve
dans une situation complexe pour ne pas
dire totalement
ubuesque la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique lui a
demandé de s'abstenir de toute démarche
auprès de ses anciens collègues du
gouvernement il ne pourra pas par
exemple s'adresser directement à
Elisabeth borne devant les députés de la
commission du développement durable il
explique comment il va faire cet avis
est un avis de compatibilité un avis
favorable avec une réserve
le contenu de cette réserve vous le
connaissez qui m'interdit de prendre des
initiatives à l'égard des anciens
membres de mon gouvernement qui serait
toujours membre de l'actuel
ce que je veux d'être important en
matière
d'ouverture à la concurrence
c'est-à-dire que tous les autres sujets
notamment ceux que j'ai déjà évoqué
avant d'évoquer celui-ci ou ce que je
vais évoquer ensuite ne sont pas
concernés par ces réserves
comme ça n'a pas été bien compris
j'ai demandé au président de la Haute
Autorité par courrier officiel de bien
vouloir me confirmer que cette
interprétation était valide ce qu'il a
fait et je tiens évidemment monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
députés à votre disposition
ce courrier du président Migaud qui
s'est par ailleurs publiquement exprimé
pourquoi confirmer ce que bon donc pour
cette ouverture la concurrence il y a un
avis de la autorité auquel des réserves
auxquelles je vais bien entendu me
conformer
deux éléments à ce titre pour vous
toutes et vous tous le premier
n'oublions quand même pas c'est que
l'ouverture la concurrence elle est
organisée non pas par le gouvernement et
mes anciens ministres mais par
IDFM et la région
c'est IDFM qui détermine les lots
et cette idée FM qui va choisir les
lauréats de ces différents lots
première chose donc je veux dire sur
l'ouverture à concurrence elle est
essentiellement de la responsabilité des
auteurs mais il y a quand même des
sujets qui peuvent relever d'État j'ai
parlé notamment du cadre réglementaire
dans ce cas là bien entendu sur ce sujet
je me conformerais à la décision de la
Haute autorité et comment faire il se
trouve que il y a un membre du
gouvernement ça tombe bien dans son
portefeuille il y a la RATP des sujets
dont nous parlons c'est Monsieur Béchu
qui ne n'a pas été membre du
gouvernement que j'ai eu l'honneur de
diriger donc je veillerai ce qu'il soit
mon point d'entrée unique sur ces sujets
d'ouverture à la concurrence pour me
conformer aux restrictions ou plutôt
réserves posées par la Haute Autorité
voilà pourquoi je vous en parle ici
parce que ce sujet
concerne l'ouverture quelque part on
peut le comprendre
puisque
intervenant dans le champ concurrentiel
il ne faudrait pas que les potentiels
concurrents de la RATP pensent que je
pourrais en tout cas le raisonnement de
la chaîne TVP
exciper de mes anciennes fonctions
auprès de mes anciens collègues pour
favoriser la RATP mais encore une fois
le décisionnel qui décidera que telle
l'eau relève de la RATP ou d'un de ces
contrats c'est
Île-de-France mobilité le droit est de
ce point de vue là extrêmement clair en
tout cas le chantier d'ouverture à la
concurrence lui va évidemment
occuper beaucoup le futur président de
la RATP ça concerne je vous le rappelle
19000 salariés c'est quand même tout à
fait considérable le chiffre d'affaires
va le périmètre financier c'est 1,5
milliards d'euros si je pars des données
actuelles donc c'est un sujet évidemment
majeur et le défi est lourd pour Jean
Castex il doit tenter de remettre en
marche une entreprise la RATP affecté
par les grèves la pénurie de conducteurs
de bus mais aussi un absentéisme
préoccupant devant les députés de la
commission du développement durable il
détaille sa feuille de route son projet
pour l'entreprise nous devons avoir
ensemble parce qu'après tout
RATP
la première contribution
de la RATP
au changement climatique c'est qu'elle
conquiert des parts de marché même pas
je parle même pas là de l'ouverture à la
concurrence parce que là le risque c'est
qu'elle perde des lots mais
même à ISO organisation
il faut que de plus en plus de gens
abandonnent la voiture pour prendre des
transports en commun c'est ça notre
enjeu collectif donc pour ça tout se
tient il faut que c'est transforme comme
un fonctionne
tout voilà bon c'est du bon sens que je
vous dis mais fait je vais le dire à
l'envers il faudrait pas que les
difficultés actuelles alors même je le
dis au député ici présent que la RATP
n'a toujours pas retrouvé sauf que
semble-t-il le week-end ces niveaux de
fréquentation d'avant la covid
alors même mais il faudrait pas
connaître
la région l'idée c'est de retrouver le
niveau de l'offre et de repartir de
l'avant par des investissements massifs
je crois là encore être cohérent quand
je suis venu devant vous parlez de la
fift auquel j'étais candidat je n'ai
cessé de dire et de faire lorsque
j'étais Premier ministre à travers le
plan de relance il faut mettre de
l'argent dans l'investissement public
pour les transports et en particulier
pour les transports collectifs et en
particulier pour les transports
collectifs j'y reviendrai dans un
instant si vous voulez bien mais en tout
cas
une fois à tout prix ne pas rater il y a
déjà quelque chose devant nous très
important là il va qui va impacter le
mandat à venir du président de la RATP
quel qu'il soit c'est évidemment
l'ouverture des lignes du Grand Paris
Express on va commencer à la faveur des
Jeux Olympiques paralympiques avec le
célèbre ligne 14 en tout cas son
prolongement au nord jusqu'à playel et
au sud jusqu'à l'aéroport d'Orly mais
vous le savez bien il y aura on va on va
augmenter on va papa doubler mais
presque 75% le linéaire du métro la RATP
est concerné à beaucoup de titres là
aussi l'exploitation des lignes je vous
le rappelle sera fera l'objet d'un appel
d'offres par la RATP mais la RATP quoi
qu'il en soit doit assurer la
maintenance de ces lignes
la sécurité sur ces lignes et déjà elle
est commettre d'ouvrage de la partie sud
de la ligne 14 et
elle doit bien mesurer elle a commencé
de le faire l'impact sur le réseau
existe de l'ouverture de Céline
nouvelles et notamment
au lieu de raccordement
il y a des travaux de modernisation
considérables à faire et nous devons
repartir de l'avoir et l'investissement
et la clé de tout l'exemple que je donne
souvent
regardé une ligne comme la ligne 1
c'est une historique comme vous le savez
de mettre ok maintenant entièrement
automatisé on a un recul
on a un recul et bien cette ligne elle
est les questions d'offre se pose
beaucoup moins une ligne
d'offres les problèmes de ponctualité de
sécurité de prévention du suicide
d'ergonomie d'informations publiques
sont bien meilleurs c'est la voix suivre
et il faudrait pouvoir accélérer sa
revient aux questions de financement
d'Île-de-France mobilité enfin des
sujets structurants que vous connaissez
mais le cap est clair me semble-t-il
pour répondre à ces questions on va
renouveler grâce à Île-de-France
mobilité plus de la moitié dans les 10
ans qui viennent du matériel roulant sur
un certain nombre de lignes bon alors là
c'est pareil meilleure
ergonomie meilleure ponctualité je
parlais du du des enjeux du
développement durable grâce à des
systèmes de freinage que ces nouveaux
matériels vont avoir grâce
à l'abaissement de leur consommation
électrique
on va contribuer à la transition
écologique de façon majeure bon donc
l'investissement c'est vraiment la clé
pour accroître nos parts de marché
l'objectif c'est clair les transports
représentent 31% des émissions de gaz à
effet de serre parmi eux la route 94 en
région Île-de-France en particulier
à distance égale on émet 50 fois moins
50 fois moins de CO2
en métro RER tramway en voiture
donc le premier défi le premier enjeu
pour l'équipe de France mobilité la RATP
et j'allais dire et tous les autres
acteurs et j'insiste sur ce point Madame
et Monsieur Je le point précédent
c'était l'ouverture à concurrence et on
comprend qu'il puisse générer des
inquiétudes etc j'ai demandé à ce qu'il
y a un observatoire parce que il faut
adresser le bilan au fil de l'eau
qu'est-ce que ça apporte vraiment
concrètement pour l'usager certains
termes de prix mais également qualité de
service là il y a pas très pragmatique
pas une religion mais vous comprenez
bien que ce sujet ne se pose pas dans
les mêmes termes
là où il y a plusieurs intervenants si
le marché croit
que s'il est un attrition
évidemment or nous avons j'ai pas ça
pour la RATP pour la nation et même pas
que pour l'île de France l'impérieuse
nécessité
de progresser de faire croire d'abord de
redémarrer puisque encore je le répète
on a perdu depuis la crise covid des
usagers de redémarrer ça c'est vraiment
j'allais dire j'ai parlé des enjeux de
très court terme tout se tient
évidemment mais c'est sans doute l'un
des priorités stratégiques parce que
l'intérêt de l'entreprise rejoint celui
des usagers et celui de la nation de la
même façon puisque le rapporteur a fait
allusion j'appelle l'attention des
députés sur cette très intéressant plan
bus pendant qu'il est lancé hein mais
voilà quelque chose de très intéressant
très intéressant l'objectif est là aussi
tout est dans l'ordre d'exécution
j'avais presque vous dire si déjà le
futur président
quelles sont vos objectifs alors il faut
grenier les objectifs si déjà je pouvais
dire tout ce qu'on a si on réussit à les
mettre à l'oeuvre plutôt que de se
glorifier d'en faire des nouveaux ce
serait déjà pas mal le plan bus 2025
Madame et Monsieur et députés il a une
cible fin 2026 on va dire 2027 pour le
PV
plus de bus diesel
sur le réseau RATP 50%
électrique et 50%
en biométhane
c'est considérable vous mesurez bien
toutes et tous l'impact en termes de
contribution et de d'émissions au gaz à
effet de serre pour l'instant il y a
bien sûr beaucoup de difficultés
vraiment fait ça on est déjà quand même
au moment où je parle devant vous
à 57% de la cible
encore du chemin et chacun sec en
général les derniers kilomètres sont un
petit peu plus compliqués que les
premiers bon ça c'est c'est pour moi
mais
il faut à tout prix atteindre cet
objectif parce que ça c'est concret
évidemment ces sommes investissements
considérables supportés encore une fois
il faut le dire par
IDFM mais
je pense que c'est le chemin qui est
tracé
alors pour terminer ce propos
introductif ce président un mot sur la
méthode
d'abord je crois qu'il faut comme je
l'ai dit au Sénat faire ce qu'on sait
faire c'est règle générale faut pas
chercher à changer donc moi ma méthode
bon ben c'est voilà c'est écoute
concertation proximité puis ensuite
décision évidemment
je l'ai déjà dit il faut que je
travaille il faut que la RATP travaille
en parfaite harmonie avec Île-de-France
mobilité donc il peut y avoir des
désaccords des bas normaux entre une
autorité organisatrice un opérateur mais
nous sommes l'opérateur historique
pour les usagers il peut pas y avoir de
guéguerre donc nous devons avec ma
Pécresse trouver les voies et moyen et
nous serons d'accord évidemment sur
l'essentiel pour atteindre les objectifs
stratégiques que j'ai sommairement
rappelé devant vous
je peux y ajouter aussi un autre grand
opérateur en Île-de-France qu'elle a
SNCF
puisque je rappelle que sur le transit
il y a le fameux RER B on a pas parlé
dans mon propre truc qui ferait beaucoup
de choses des grands objectifs sur le
RER B j'ai été pendant très longtemps un
usager du RER B et j'en connais toutes
les saveurs bon et vous savez qu'il est
exploité je parlais tout à l'heure là de
des incidents au Stade de France il y
avait un jour de grève donc il y avait
rupture de charge à la gare du Nord au
nord par la SNCF au sud par la RATP là
aussi voilà il faut faire en sorte que
les usagers ne soient pas les victimes
collatérales d'une organisation qui
historique qui est assez fondement sans
doute mais il faut travailler et il faut
que les enjeux de pouvoir de chacun
c'est de le pas aux enjeux d'efficacité
et de services publics toujours
évidemment dans la même ligne c'est le
dialogue social
c'est une entreprise évidemment marquée
par une tradition des aides sociales par
des organisations
syndicales
fortes
bon c'est quelque chose qui non
seulement ne m'a pas comme une
contrainte mais j'ai toujours vous le
savez
considéré que le dialogue social
dialogue avec les corps intermédiaires
étaient absolument indispensables c'est
pas simple c'est exigeant mais on ne
voilà il faut se donner les moyens
d'avoir un dialogue social de qualité je
rappelle qu'il existe bien sûr il y a
demain une grève qui s'annonce
extrêmement suivie me dit me disait
dirigeants actuels de la RATP
n'oubliez pas quand même que on a des
chiffres de taux de conflictualité comme
on dit
qui
ne sont pas ce qu'ils furent il y a
quelques décennies passées et que sur
tous les accords d'entreprise sont de
multiples sujets sont vivaces il y en a
déjà
presque une bonne dizaine qui ont été
conclus depuis le début de l'année 2022
donc il faut absolument approfondir ça
et continuer sur cette voie je voudrais
aussi penser aux usagers
il y a des usagers RATP vers maison moi
organiser que les organisations
syndicales mais je vais essayer terme
d'un premier diagnostic de voir comment
encore davantage approfondir le lien
avec eux et puis en interne je l'ai dit
Catherine Gillouard a déjà conduit une
réorganisation extrêmement importante
notamment pour faire face aux défis de
l'ouverture à la concurrence
je suis un grand partisan de la
déconcentration des responsabilités
c'est impératif c'est une boîte qui
aujourd'hui dépasse les 70 000 salariés
il faut tout prix que la ligne
hiérarchique la chaîne hiérarchique soit
pleinement investi je veux dire je ne
préjuge en rien à ce que vous dites vous
avez devant vous un candidat pas
quelqu'un qui connaît intimement la
boîte pour vous donner des certitudes
faut-il d'ailleurs jamais en avoir mais
en tout cas une conviction un principe
il faut que le management à tous les
étages puissent être valorisés par tout
moyen et c'est absolument indispensable
dans le cadre notamment de structure
importante
j'ai dit ma priorité ce sera le cœur de
métier la vie quotidienne j'ai parlé la
ponctualité j'ai longuement développé au
Sénat je peux pas faire les mêmes
auditions les questions de sécurité les
questions de propreté les questions
d'information les questions de
convivialité j'ai demandé combien il y a
de personnels RATP en dehors de ça qui
font des des contrôles et bien entendu
des machines c'est là qui sont dans les
stations qui sont et qui font de
l'humain la relation humaine d'accord
comment concilier le grand défi
billettique et numérique il faut surtout
pas reculer là-dessus il faut même
accélérer mais on va redéployer les
moyens que cette productivité gagnée
doit nous faire économiser vers le
terrain vers la relation humaine vers le
client usager
là c'est vraiment un de mes objectifs il
y a déjà plusieurs milliers d'agents
RATP qui sont dans les gars dans les
stations bon et il faut voir comment ils
sont répartis et si on peut encore faire
mieux ou d'avance
bref
c'est un sujet majeur il y aurait
beaucoup de choses à dire monsieur
paysan je pense je termine là-dessus
avoir une certaine expérience à faire
valoir pour relever tous ces défis je
pense qu'il faut une vision transversale
je le dis devant des députés
pardonne vous le dire mais le fait
d'avoir fait de la politique alors on
est d'accord ou pas encore reçu ça c'est
la démocratie ne m'a pas être handicap
n'ayons pas honte de voilà c'est une
autre façon de s'occuper des autres mais
c'est l'intérêt général qui est encore
je suis de ceux qui ont toujours cru que
le service public
doit rester le service public tout en
n'ayant pas à craindre les mots ni
concurrence ni efficient ni
compétitivité pas des gros mots
simplement il faut que ça ne doit pas
être au détriment de l'accomplissement
des missions et des valeurs
fondamentales du service public bon
au vu de tout ça je présente monsieur le
rapporteur c'est vrai que je
suis très enthousiaste je suis lucide
rassurez-vous je vois bien la somme
depuis si par hasard je l'avais oublié
on me le rappelle tous les jours la
somme des difficultés qui sont vraiment
mais de ce point de vue là on est tous
fait pareil c'est c'est justement c'est
difficile qu'il faut y aller
c'est justement parce que c'est
difficile ouais bon je pourrais rester
sur mon statut d'ancien Premier ministre
sûr que la fille par exemple c'est
moins d'exposition comme on dit oui mais
bon le devoir est d'aller là où il y a
un enjeu fort pour nos concitoyens me
semble-t-il c'est l'objet même de ce que
nous sommes censés devoir faire je vous
remercie pour le groupe Renaissance la
parole est à David Valence
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre il y a 105 jours le 27
juillet vous étiez devant notre
commission et votre nomination à la
présidence de l'Agence de financement
des infrastructures de transport il y
avait été validé nul ne pouvait imaginer
alors que le premier septembre Madame
Catherine guyoire président directrice
générale de la RATP déciderait de
démissionner le président de la
République vous propose aujourd'hui pour
lui succéder il faudra il est vrai des
qualités signalées pour réussir dans
cette mission à la tête d'une entreprise
symbole de l'excellence française en
matière de transport vous avez été
délégué interministériel à
l'organisation des Jeux olympiques et
paralympiques vous savez le défi qu'il
représente avec la Coupe du monde de
rugby pour les transports franciliens
vous êtes en outre un fin connaisseur
des sujets d'infrastructures or la RATP
sera le gestionnaire des 200 km des
voies nouvelles du Grand Paris Express
ouverte au circulation et à la
concurrence entre 2024 et 2030 c'est un
réseau presque comparable en étendu à
celui de l'actuel métro parisien
l'ouverture à la concurrence est une
autre un autre défi et je souhaiterais
en particulier que vous reveniez devant
nous en détail sur la manière dont vous
voyez à l'avenir l'articulation entre le
cœur de métier de la RATP et les
activités de ratpv en France à
Boulogne-sur-Mer ou Charleville-Mézières
par exemple et à l'étranger à Florence à
Alger ou aux États-Unis ou RATP devrait
présente monsieur le Premier ministre il
vous définissez vous-même comme un
gaulliste social il faudra beaucoup de
passion du service public de sens du
dialogue social et de goût du projet
pour emmener la RATP et ses salariés
dans les années qui viennent vers ces
nouveaux défis le rapporteur sur votre
nomination c'est là pourtant élue
d'opposition a reconnu que vous
réunissiez toutes les compétences pour
réussir nous sommes très nombreux à le
penser ici à l'avoir encore constaté à
l'instant pour toutes ces raisons les
députés Renaissance et apparentés
voteront favorablement à la nomination
de à votre nomination à la tête de notre
RATP puisqu'elle appartient aux Français
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
rassemblement national la parole est à
Alexandra Masson
merci Monsieur le Premier Ministre 3
millions de personnes empruntent chaque
jour le réseau de bus de la RATP la
région autonome des transports parisiens
mais celle-ci doit faire face à de
graves dysfonctionnements depuis
plusieurs semaines comme vous l'avez
vous-même rappelé à Paris sa petite
couronne 26% des bus escomptés ne
circulent pas dans le métro parisien la
situation n'est pas meilleure la rigueur
était des rames était inférieure de 10%
à 20% à la normale au mois de septembre
ma première question est donc simple
même si vous y avez partiellement
répondu que comptez-vous faire pour
rétablir rapidement un service de
qualité pour les clients de la RATP en
particulier dans la capitale monsieur
Castex le 27 juillet dernier vous étiez
auditionné par notre commission en fin
de recevoir notre travail pour prendre
la présidence de l'Agence de financement
des infrastructures de transport ma
deuxième question va donc concerner
votre job Hopper l'anglicisme utilisé
pour une personne touchée par une
instabilité professionnelle chronique
vous aviez indiqué vouloir agir à la
fuite sur le des termes il y a deux mois
est-ce l'ennui la quête du meilleur
salaire ou la recherche du meilleur
pantouflage qui me motive votre arrivée
à la RATP d'autres souligne votre amour
du ferroviaire ce qui nous fait craindre
que vous ne changiez à nouveau pour la
SNCF prochainement alors que trois mois
avant de prendre la présence de l'affite
vous affirmiez vous-même dans la presse
vouloir aller repeindre vos volets et
votre rempart de dans les Pyrénées vous
avez peut-être d'autres comme vous
l'avez mentionné avant qu'on puisse vous
poser la question la Haute autorité pour
la transparence de la vie publique a
donné son accord à votre arrivée à la
RATP à la condition que vous abstenir de
toutes démarches qu'en 2025 auprès des
anciens ministres de votre gouvernement
nous ne voyons pas comment vous
envisager sérieusement de pouvoir
travailler sur les grands dossiers de
mise en concurrence entre autres vous
l'avez dit la concurrence transport
parisien qui va s'ouvrir les transports
des passagers pour la Coupe du monde de
rugby en 2023 puis les JO de Paris en
2024 et ce vol malgré vos explications
qui ne sont pas convaincantes ni
réaliste dans ces conditions vous
l'aurez compris nous voterons évidemment
pas en faveur de votre nomination merci
chers collègues pour le groupe la France
insoumise du peste la parole est à
Clémence guetter merci Président
Monsieur le Premier Ministre c'est juste
un enfer des temps d'attente de 30
minutes pour des bus blindés le RER B
c'est la pire ligne je vais me taper 2
heures de trajet ce matin au lieu de 45
minutes quand j'ai de la chance ces
témoignages évidemment sur la galère
quotidienne dans les transports en
commun en Île-de-France nous les avons
par centaines et je les vis aussi comme
usagère comme certains de mes collègues
les Franciliens sont écrasés dans des
wagons bondés ils sont en retard et ils
souffrent physiquement de leur trajet
quotidien à tel point que les groupes de
gauche au conseil régional ont saisi la
Défenseur des droits sur cette situation
qui dure depuis des mois et dont les
causes sont connues avec l'ouverture à
la concurrence en cours dont vous avez
parlé c'est un financier qui coûte 5
milliards on fait tout pour grappiller
le moindre centime résultat pour les
salariés des conducteurs de bus
travaillent une heure de plus par jour
sans compensation financière les primes
passent à la trappe et les salaires
restent faibles les embauches se font de
moins en moins en CDI et sous statut le
nombre de jours d'arrêt maladie a
quasiment doublé entre 2018 et 2021
quand les dépenses pour l'amélioration
des conditions de travail ont été
divisées par 3 dans la même période le
matériel est défectueux et des bus
prennent feu la RATP doit donc cesser de
maltraiter ces personnels et ses usagers
c'est la raison évidemment de la grève
de demain je dis 10 novembre les
solutions aussi sont connues dans
l'immédiat évidemment il faut dédommager
les usagers et geler le prix du Pass
Navigo un moyen terme il faudrait
annuler cette ouverture à la concurrence
embaucher massivement augmenter les
salaires et cesser de faire passer des
transports pour les riches comme le
Charles de Gaulle express en priorité
par rapport aux lignes du quotidien on
peut douter que ce soit vos priorités à
Matignon vous avez déjà soutenu les
projets routiers ultra polluants et
coupez les fonds de la SNCF vous vous
attaquez maintenant à la RATP main dans
la main avec Madame Pécresse il faut
dire que les 450 000 euros annuels que
toucher votre prédécesseur sont plus
alléchants que les maigres 3500 mensuels
de la FIFA dès lors on sait que vous
n'agirez pas pour mettre un terme à ce
désastre et vous n'aurez ni votre vote
ni notre confiance merci pour le groupe
les républicains la parole est à Antoine
vers Morelle marquez merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
je me réjouis de votre présence devant
nous ce matin grâce à la révision
constitutionnelle de 2008 les
nominations importantes ne sont plus le
fait du prince mais requiert désormais
Laval des assemblées et la
représentation nationale et le Parlement
y ont beaucoup gagné vous avez apporté
de nombreux éléments de réponse à nos
questions hier devant nos collègues du
Sénat néanmoins quelques questions du
groupe les républicains à l'Assemblée
nationale restent en suspens la première
et qui nous semble importante dans le
débat sur les retraites qui arrivent en
France concerne votre position en tant
que futur PDG mais aussi en tant
qu'enseigne Premier ministre l'homme qui
se présente devant nous est-il celui de
2020 qui affirmait à la tribune de cette
assemblée que le contexte budgétaire je
cite implique clairement la disparition
des régimes spéciaux notamment ceux des
fonctionnaires de la RATP quel est votre
position personnelle en la matière et
qu'elle sera celle du futur PDG de la
RATP la deuxième question concerne
l'accessibilité des transports en commun
francilien la loi de 2005 entreprises
par Jacques Chirac imposait une mise en
conformité dans des délais contraints
des services publics son article 41
exigeait je cite que dans un délai de 10
ans les services de transport collectifs
devront être accessibles aux personnes
handicapées et à mobilité réduite
plusieurs années après ce délai seulent
3% des stations de métro à Paris sont
accessibles aux personnes en situation
de handicap alors que les métros de Los
Angeles ou Washington sont 100%
accessibles quel est votre plan en la
matière et enfin la troisième question
concerne la sécurité dans les transports
en commun selon un sondage récent près
de la moitié des usagers redoutent une
agression ou un vol dans le métro ou le
RER quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre
pour sécuriser nos transports en commun
en fonction de la précision de vos
éléments de réponse notre groupe se
positionnera avec bienveillance votre
nomination je vous remercie
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
démocrate modem est indépendant la
parole est à ode Luke merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier ministre
vous avez déjà apporté un certain nombre
de réponses dans le questionnaire qui
vous a été transmis dans votre propos
introductif cependant j'aimerais revenir
sur quelques points tout d'abord
l'attractivité du métier de conducteur
au sein de la RATP et plus largement de
l'entreprise elle-même vous avez indiqué
évoqué des solutions que contient sur
les problèmes de recrutement sur le
climat social sur l'ouverture à la
concurrence sur ce dernier point avant
son départ Catherine Gillouard a partagé
une crainte supplémentaire sur ce sujet
à savoir que cela pourrait remettre en
question l'attachement des salariés à
leur activité ou à leur entreprise et
donc renforcer le défaut d'attractivité
du groupe est-ce pour vous monsieur le
Premier ministre une crainte justifiée
comment renforcer plus largement la
tractivité de la RATP fasse à cette
concurrence qui se profile j'aimerais
revenir également sur les enjeux liés à
la transition écologique et
technologique de l'entreprise
électrification du réseau de bus lutte
contre la pollution colère au sein des
stations nouvelles mobilités logiques
logistique urbaine les enjeux de la
ville de demain sont considérables pour
y répondre a été créé l'année dernière
RATP solution ville avec l'objectif
d'être le partenaire privilégié des
villes intelligentes humaines et
durables la question est donc 5 quelle
place pour la RATP dans la ville de
demain quelle place pour les nouvelles
technologies au sein de l'entreprise je
pense par exemple à l'usage de la vidéo
intelligente enfin je terminerai sur un
sujet qui me qui me tient
particulièrement à coeur et qui a été
évoqué par le précédent orateur à savoir
l'accessibilité des transports pour les
personnes notamment en fauteuil on le
sait les bus parisien et les tramways
sont 100% accessibles ce n'est pas le
cas pour les bus de banlieue et
concernant le métro seule la ligne 14
est accessible pour ces personnes donc
de nombreux progression donc attendus
donc ma dernière question quelles
actions comptez-vous mener pour rendre
nos transports accessibles à tous et
pour conclure sachez que le Mouvement
Démocrate soutient votre candidature
merci
merci chers collègues pour le groupe
socialiste et apparenté la parole est à
Fatiha qui loichi oui merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Premier Ministre
dans un con c'est dans un contexte
périlleux qui a lieu aujourd'hui votre
nomination la tête de la RATP comme vous
le savez cette dernière se trouve
aujourd'hui dans une situation
particulièrement inquiétante entre
usager exaspéré par les temps d'attente
toujours plus longs et des responsables
syndicaux qui dénoncent de mauvaises
conditions de travail à cela s'ajoute
les Jeux Olympiques et l'enjeu de
l'ouverture à la concurrence le prochain
PDG de la RATP de droit donc marcher sur
des œufs votre nomination intervient à
peine trois mois après avoir rejoint la
présidence de la Fife remplaçant
Christophe Béchu
un véritable jeu de chaises musicales
auxquelles nous assistons depuis le
début de cette législature et alors que
nous pensions que cette musique s'était
arrêtée la voilà à nouveau en marche
sans doute sans doute de vos compétences
Monsieur le Premier Ministre cette
nomination nous semble problématique à
plusieurs égards joignons nos doutes à
celle de la Haute autorité pour la
transparence de la vie publique en effet
d'un point de vue symbolique
ce jeu de chaise musicale nuit au pacte
républicain culture vivant dans l'esprit
de nos concitoyens l'image d'un entre
soi qui distend chaque jour un peu plus
la confiance envers les représentants
politiques d'un point de vue pratique
cela nous interdirait d'entreprendre
vous interdirez pardon d'entreprendre de
nombreuses démarches auprès des anciens
membres de votre gouvernement de votre
cabinet et de des administrations jadis
passait sous votre autorité dans le
cadre de cette ouverture à la
concurrence que vous qualifiez-vous même
auprès du rapporteur de défi majeur pour
comment dès lors imaginer un PDG de la
réalité qu'il puisse répondre à ce défi
sans contact avec le Premier ministre ou
avec la ministre des Transports le 27
juillet dernier enfin devant cette même
commission vous disiez au sujet de la
FIF avoir accepté avec beaucoup
d'enthousiasme parce que vous acceptez
avec beaucoup d'enthousiasme cette
présidence de de la FIF nous vous
proposons d'y rester en poste donc nous
ne donnerons pas un avis favorable à
votre nomination
et à part et apparentés la parole est à
Xavier
Albertini monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Rapporteur mes chers collègues
monsieur le Premier ministre dans depuis
la rentrée la RATP est devenu un sujet
récurrent pour les journalistes et pas
seulement des pages locales du Parisien
lundi encore dernier elle faisait
l'objet d'un article dans une dans les
pages oranges du Figaro métro à Paris la
pression monte sur la RATP et la photo
illustrant l'article montre une rame de
métro archi bondée c'est la dimension
nationale caprice la crise de la RATP il
faut dire que la Régie autonome des
transports parisiens c'est 3500 millions
3000 3500000 usagers quotidiens
transportés aux quatre coins de la
région capital et que la moindre nicoche
a un effet papillon et force est de
constater que les Franciliens sont à
crans utilisent les transports est
devenu une source d'hyper stress
Monsieur le Premier Ministre vous
apprêtez à prendre la tête des
entreprises françaises les plus
prestigieuses de notre pays mais qui
connaît un groupe trou d'air sur le fond
d'ouverture la concurrence la RATP et le
théâtre d'importants complices sociaux
vous aurez ces tours de tâches de
trouver très rapidement les voies du
dialogue pour que la journée de grève de
demain soit la dernière de l'année vous
aurez aussi la lourde tâche de trouver
les solutions pour établir un trafic à
100% du métro comme des bus dans une
conjoncture de carence aggravée du
personnel formé là où la crise ne
touchait que le réseau de bus il y a
quelques semaines 25% du trafic en moi
elle se répercute désormais sur le
réseau métro il a objectivement un
manque d'anticipation à la RATP par le
passé une mauvaise projection des
besoins postes covid et le manque
d'anticipation d'autant plus inquiétant
que la
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre chers collègues depuis
quelques semaines les rames du métro
parisien sont saturés les quais sont
bondés et les malaises se multiplient en
plus de la ligne 13 qui est l'une des
plus fréquentées au monde les lignes 3 4
6 8 11 12 présente un graphe problème de
régularité la RATP peine aussi depuis la
rentrée à assurer son offre de bus avec
25% de service non fait à Paris et en
petite couronne les difficultés
d'exploitation de la RATP ne viennent
pas de la légère baisse de l'offre
voulue par Île-de-France mobilité la
cause réelle et bien le manque de
conducteur de bus et maintenant de métro
les difficultés de recrutement et les
démissions en masse des conducteurs sont
inédites l'ouverture à la concurrence
qui approche ne motive vraisemblablement
pas les éventuels candidats qui
s'inquiètent du risque de fortes
dégradations des conditions de travail
qui en découleraient aujourd'hui un
conducteur commence déjà avec un salaire
de 1800 euros net en Île-de-France ça
n'attire plus les syndicats demandent
une augmentation de salaire de 300 euros
par mois
parmi les autres causes à l'origine de
ce manque de conducteur les départs en
retraite massif la hausse de
l'absentéisme depuis le covid-19 la
concurrence des autres secteurs en
tension mais aussi sûrement une crise
plus profonde selon Christophe Cabaud le
délégué CGT des conducteurs il n'y a pas
une ligne qui s'en sort correctement il
manque entre 140 et 150 conducteurs de
métro monsieur Castex vous avez évoqué
ces difficultés dans votre propos
liminaire mais qu'envisagez-vous de
mettre en place pour attirer les
nombreux conducteurs qui permettraient
d'assurer un service de qualité à
l'heure où plus que jamais la lutte
contre le réchauffement climatique nous
invite à développer les transports en
commun et en améliorer l'efficacité
par ailleurs comment comptez-vous gérer
les gros dossiers liés à ce poste dont
le plus important vous l'avez cité
l'ouverture à la concurrence alors que
la Haute autorité pour la transparence
de la vie publique vous invite à ce
sujet à ne pas entrer en contact avec
vos anciens collègues ministres encore
au gouvernement parmi lesquels le
ministre des Transports Clément bonne
est la première ministre Elisabeth borne
vous l'avez dit vous pourrez échanger
avec Monsieur Béchu c'est bien et
changer directement avec les ministres
directement concernés ça nous semblerait
légèrement plus efficace ces conditions
ne vous permettront vraisemblablement
pas d'exercer l'émission liées à ce
poste correctement et dans ces
conditions les écologistes préféreront
éviter de vous mettre dans une telle
difficulté et votre votre nom démocrate
et républicaine la parole est à
uberulfran
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre bonjour
alors madame guetter a relu avec
attention le diagnostic de l'humain qui
est sorti il y a peu de temps sur la
RATP oui vous arrivez en plein orage
social après effectivement
[Musique]
l'initiation de la mise en concurrence
impulsé vous l'avez dit effectivement
par Valérie Pécresse mais qu'en tant que
homme politique d'hier et d'aujourd'hui
vous avez accompagné y compris sur
d'autres moyens de transport majeurs
pour notre pays alors bon la logique on
la connaît elle s'installe
l'Île-de-France a racheté l'ensemble des
moyens de production et à être plus
qu'on prestataire que vous êtes et bien
attiré sur les salaires et les
conditions de travail
ce que ce que vous faites via parce que
fait la RATP via le cadre social territ
mise en oeuvre depuis donc le mois
d'août tout ça ça se décline par la
perte d'acquis sociaux majeur alors
travaille supplémentaire par jour sans
compensation financière suppression de
la prime de 12 euros et des 20 minutes
abondant le temps de travail
supplémentaire en cas de service en deux
vacations
des primes passées à la trappe sur deux
maigres rémunération et la perspective
donc de perdre à l'année 6 jours de
repos sans compter ce qui vous attend
sur la question des retraites donc moi
ma réflexion elle est simple
[Musique]
c'est là le cœur de l'enjeu parce que on
peut améliorer les conditions de
transport pour les voyagesseurs on peut
avoir un objectif légitime
d'environnement mais d'abord ça passe
par les hommes alors est-ce que vous
êtes prêts à vous remettre autour de la
Dame des négociations pour visiter
sérieusement effectivement
c'est c'est un port sociaux dans
l'entreprise qui sont absolument
dégradés à l'heure actuelle merci chers
collègues pour le groupe liberté
indépendant outre-mer et territoires la
parole
est à
Jean-Louis Bricout
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
rapporteur monsieur le Premier ministre
nous l'aurons collectivement compris
l'ambition que vous souhaitez pouvoir
porter à la tête de la RATP relève si
l'on veut synthétiser d'un couple défi
le défi d'ouverture la concurrence qui
doit se faire à mon sens ni au détriment
de la qualité de service pour les
usagers ni au détriment des enjeux
sociaux en interne le défi du Grand
Paris Express le défi de la gestion des
grands événements comme Paris 2024 le
défi de la modernisation des équipements
et le déploiement des services de
mobilité connectés le défi aussi la
transition écologique au sein de de
laquelle l'intermodalité constitue un
enjeu stratégique
vous l'avez rappelé et
vous en êtes convaincu au carrefour de
ces grands défis l'air a été fait et
vous à sa tête restez confiant notre
groupe est dans le même état d'esprit
avec quelques réserves sur l'image
renvoyée par votre nomination on attend
de vous bien évidemment d'exceller dans
dans l'écoute la concertation à notre
égard et à l'ensemble des corps
intermédiaires et bien sûr comme vous
vous y êtes engagé respecter les
réserves mentionnées par la haute par la
Haute Autorité notre groupe souhaite
également avoir des compléments
d'information sur deux points le premier
point concerne l'accessibilité des
personnes à mobilité réduite on a
quelques fois le sentiment que dans ce
domaine elle RATP à métaux un métro de
retard vous pourrez le dire comme ça
comment entendez-vous accélérer cette
accessibilité dans le métro et proposer
une vraie inter modalité pour les
déplacements d'un point à un point B
adapté aux personnes concernées je crois
qu'il y a pas pire situation qu'une
rupture d'accessibilité dans un trajet
donc il y a des enjeux autour de de
l'information
et notamment la concertation avec les
autres opérateurs de transport les
personnes à mobilier réutilisent à
mobilité réduite feront-elles l'objet
d'un traitement particulier dans le cas
du déploiement de la masse mobilité
service et le deuxième point concerne
l'accélération de la transition
énergétique et des objectifs de
décarbonate de décarbonation et puis
pour terminer avant de changer de cap
Monsieur le Premier Ministre comment est
évaluez vous votre bilan à la tête de la
fuite merci chers collègues l'ensemble
des orateurs de groupes ont pu
s'exprimer monsieur le Premier je vais
aussi la parole en sachant que nous
avons d'ores et déjà 12 questions de
plus de plus je vous en prie Monsieur le
Premier Ministre
moi je suis je le dis à votre
disposition autant de temps que vous
souhaitez et si on peut pas en fonction
de des horaires que vous avez donné je
répondrai volontiers par écrit à toute
question complémentaire que les membres
de la commission souhaiteraient je le
dis au passage bon je vais tenter de
répondre je reviens sur les sujets que
connexe c'est à dire sur le principe
même de ma nomination ce qui est bien
quand même c'est à dire que même ceux
qui s'oppose c'est pour moi l'essentiel
je dois le dire ne semble pas douter en
tout cas de ma compétence c'est quand
même me semble-t-il le premier critère
pour nommer un emploi public je ne sais
pas il faudrait interroger l'opinion
publique pour savoir puisque monsieur
Bricout lui-même employé cette
expression quelle est l'image renvoyée
par ma nomination bon j'espère qu'elle
n'est pas mauvaise mais bon en tout cas
j'entends tout ce que vous dites mais je
veux dire
je le dis pour la repentante du Parti
socialiste je n'ai pas du tout le
sentiment de m'inscrire dans un jeu de
chaise musicale j'ai expliqué pourquoi
enfin moi j'ai toujours eu une appétence
très forte madame la députée pour les
transports toujours pas nouveau j'en
profite pour vous savez on gagne pas
tous les coups c'est normal j'ai vu
candidat c'était dans la presse à la
présence de la SNCF il y a quelques
années
j'ai pas eu le bonheur d'arriver
jusqu'au bout j'étais candidat en 2019
ça a été d'un jour loop voilà j'ai pas
été nommé aujourd'hui je suis candidat à
la RATP j'espère je vais être en tout
cas
comme j'ai dit si vous ne m'accordez pas
le le bénéfice de votre suprage au moins
accordément celui de la cohérence je
suis pas dans une recherche de postes où
je sais pas bon il y a quelqu'un ici je
m'en doutais bien évoqué la question des
salaires ou c'est pas moi qui est fixé
le salaire de la RATP voilà je bon c'est
pas c'est pas Madame soyez assurée je
pense que vous connaissez c'est ma
motivation ne se situe pas là
bon ma motivation ne se situe pas là bon
ma motivation c'est de servir le service
public et mon pays c'est pas d'être dans
un jeu la RATP se trouvait être vacan
dans les conditions que chacun rappelait
on m'a dit est-ce que j'ai pas
j'ai pas voulu moi prendre l'initiative
cardidaire ça éveillé une petite lumière
à moi je suis très honnête avec vous
quand ce poste a été mais pourquoi
justement pour la raison que vous avez
dites puis parce que bon voilà je j'ai
j'étais à la fuite je veux dire le matin
à la RATP ne part pas d'une
insatisfaction dans ce que je faisais à
la fille ou ailleurs pas du tout bon
c'est que je pense que il y a des enjeux
encore plus forts et que je peux être
utile vous êtes parfaitement libre et
c'est l'objet même de ce jeu
démocratique comme la rappeler je crois
le le député représentant les
républicains que de Parlement se
prononce cette une bonne innovation mais
en tout cas moi c'est mon intention je
pense que je peux être encore plus utile
je veux dire comme ça à la RATP car la
fille bon donc je le dis pour tout le
monde c'est je pense qu'il faut mettre
ça et comme j'ai dit à vos collègues du
cerf d'habitude je vous invite à faire
ça quand on veut caser ou recaser des
gens ou des amis ça aussi
d'habitude on le fait plutôt dans des
sinécures vous voyez jusqu'au bout je ne
suis pas certain je ne suis pas certain
que ce soit l'objet du poste qui nous
réunit ce matin bon bref toi bon ma
question est pour moi et je croyais bien
que celle-là elle me elle me tarotte
est-ce que je vais être à la hauteur de
la tâche je me suis posé évidemment
mesdames et messieurs les députés la
même question lorsque la proposition m'a
été faite de devenir Premier ministre
cela pose tous en permanence évidemment
bon mais si j'ai pris la décision de me
présenter devant vous c'est encore une
fois j'ai la conviction qu'elle RATP
c'est vraiment un levier très fort
qu'elle a des ressources considérables
et que je peux apporter quelque chose
d'autre sûrement aussi mais bon voilà
quand je reviens encore à la vie d'un
chat TVP bon
les choses sont claires oui ces
circonscrit à la concurrence mais comme
l'ont rappelé deux intervenant c'est pas
le sujet majeur
mais que dit la chattevp
il faut la citer jusqu'au bout tant
qu'on y est hein je fais pas de
commentaire moi j'applique que moi je ne
peux pas prendre l'initiative sur ce
sujet d'entrer en contact avec
des ministres qui ont été dans mon
gouvernement dont j'ai répondu mais ben
ça tombe bien il y en a un qui a le les
transports dans son décret d'attribution
qui n'était pas dans mon gouvernement
mais lisons la vie d'un chat type
péchelou les autres ministres a commencé
par la première d'entre eux eux bien
entendu peuvent avoir des contacts avec
moi sur ces sujets mais la concurrence
donc quand vous dites que je serai sans
contact non pas du tout les liens sont
rétablissent seront dans le cas de fixés
par la hache atvp et je le répète que je
respecterai un peu chacun est libre
commentaire particulier le législateur
mais certainement pas
les intéressés et j'en fais partie
j'appliquerai la vie d'achatp mais
excusez-moi mais si j'avais le sentiment
moi ce que je veux c'est agir encore une
fois que cette délibération
m'empêchait d'ailleurs je sais pas
devant vous ce matin
de faire bon alors je crois que tout ça
a été clarifié a commencé par le
président de la chatvp il faut être
scrupuleux on a fait c'est un progrès il
y a une tout ça est contrôlé des
conflits d'intérêt elle a commencé par
dire il y a pas conflit intérêt le
risque pénal est écarté bon il y a un
sujet effectivement qui peut poser
question c'est la question à l'ouverture
à contraste voilà comment nous fixons
les règles du jeu pour fluidifier des
choses
effectivement vous avez raison il faut
veiller à ce que l'application de cette
distribution n'empêche pas comment dire
le fonctionnement régulier du service et
le fonctionnement régulier des pouvoirs
publics la question David Valence me
permet je viens maintenant au fond des
choses
de parler d'un sujet sur les filiales
RATP développement etc vous savez
mesdames et messieurs les députés que ça
s'est beaucoup développé pendant
les dernières décennies pas que sous le
mandat de ma prédécesseur même si elle a
eu un rôle extrêmement actif mais il y a
un moment que la RATP sort de
l'Île-de-France elle a comme qui des
marchés ou des concessions de transport
urbains dans beaucoup de grandes villes
notamment d'ailleurs plutôt à l'ouest du
pays et puis vous l'avez dit dans bien
d'autres pays
je poursuis vrai
c'est votre question cette ce mouvement
sur des bases qui sont les suivantes
d'abord il faut que cette politique de
diversification et de finalisation
soit sur la base de ce que nous savons
faire il y a quelques cohérents
on reste par exemple à l'étranger je
pense qu'il faut aller de plus en plus
vers le métro automatique parce que là
on a un savoir-faire incontestable
incontestable et il faut aussi bien
choisir ses zones vous lisez comme moi
vous avez su profondé mais il y a
quelques pays où nous sommes allés ou
enfin la RATP est et qui se sont révélés
particulièrement compliqué on va dire ça
comme ça
donc oui c'est la même façon je crois
que c'est important du MoDem qui m'a
parlé de RATP solution ville moi ce que
j'aime beaucoup dans ce concept c'est
que une entreprise de transport puis
toujours elle ne fait pas que
transporter déjà c'est le cœur de métier
mais elle restructure un paysage urbain
ou rural si c'est une entreprise de
transport dans le milieu elle
restructure donc que la RATP apporte sa
contribution
à la conception du tissu urbain autour
des gars etc et développe ou propose des
solutions dans ce domaine je crois qu'il
faut encore accélérer de la même façon
la RATP je l'ai déjà dit
et c'est le point commun avec les trois
sujets elle a développé une expertise
sur certains métiers
qu'il faut encore approfondir et vendre
exporter à l'extérieur bon je le dis
aussi pour j'entends là sur le
l'ouverture à la congrange je vais y
revenir mais il faut quand même faire
attention à dire oui on va essayer
d'exporter notre technologie d'exporter
de d'exploiter des bus en Toscane du
métro ici ou là et dire ben oui non mais
chez nous évidemment personne ne pourra
venir ça évidemment il y a une petite
limite là bon donc je crois qu'en grande
phase qui va réconcilier tout ça ce qui
doit c'est la progression massive des
transports en commun
encore une fois si on en fait moins bon
et la deuxième chose que j'ai dit tu
hier au Sénat c'est pas du tout comment
dire pour atténuer ça mais c'est bien
pour recadrer
il faut travailler c'est marcher nouveau
d'accord mais ne jamais laisser croire
jamais que c'est en quoi que ce soit au
détriment du cœur de métier alors si je
deviens Président Directeur Général RATP
je peux pas expliquer qu'on exploite
très bien
un réseau de transport en commun dans
n'importe quelle ville du monde sous
l'étiquette RATP pas celui
d'Île-de-France
qui va pas bien là Monsieur bon en
raison
ils ont raison bon alors voilà c'est pas
dire ah mais je vais arrêter pas du tout
il faut remettre bien les choses dans le
bon ordre
sur le justement l'ouverture à la
concurrence bon
encore une fois moi j'ai dit sur ces
sujets
c'est pas une religion faut que ce soit
moyen et que nous veillons à ce que
à l'arrivée
le résultat soit meilleur qu'au départ
ça ne peut pas être au détriment ni de
la qualité du service ni des conditions
de travail ça ça se mesure et ça
s'observe j'ai mis ce feu hier au Sénat
que ce soit ça a commencé déjà
c'est un peu déjà regardez étirer
quelques enseignements de façon neutre
externe évidemment bon mais
le cadre social territorialisé oui c'est
vrai que ça va amener des nations qui
n'ont pas encore abouti donc je rappelle
que vous avez cité évidemment des
éléments négatifs en tout cas présenter
il y a quand même un 14e mois derrière
14e mois notamment on parle des
conducteurs de bus puisque c'est eux qui
sont comme je l'ai dit les premiers
concernés et puis ce cadre social
territorisé il a vocation à s'impliquer
à tous les opérateurs je ne me
mais de compte à rendre qui
éventuellement pour la RATP je me dis
mais il y a tous les autres aussi pour
lesquels ce cadre social territorialisé
en tout cas pour les salariés lesquels
peut être un progrès bon parce que
évidemment il s'agit d'harmoniser les
conditions de la concurrence bon
mais il y a encore beaucoup de sujets à
régler je l'ai dit
et je comprends du coup que ça
inclinquiète beaucoup donc quand
plusieurs d'entre vous me demandent si
je suis prêt à me réimpliquer là-dedans
je vais revisiter
c'est le premier job du président de
RATP bien sûr ça inquiète tout n'est pas
réglé je vois tout ce qu'il y a dans le
mais en même temps je pars pas battu
d'avance en disant voilà tout ça ne
marchera pas ça va être une catastrophe
non faut se donner les moyens j'ai
besoin on a besoin l'autorité
organisatrice de la concurrence comme
les opérateurs vous voyez que quelqu'un
regarde un peu comment ça se passe
qu'est-ce qu'il faut corriger qu'est-ce
qu'il faut changer en fait très
pragmatique l'objectif la finalité c'est
pas la concurrence elle-même c'est en
quoi le service est-il amélioré et je ne
connais pas de service qui soit
améliorés c'est les usagers ou les
agents y perdent ça ça existe pas
oui il faut faire bouger les choses il
faut améliorer des choses quand là comme
ailleurs bon donc c'est un sujet
évidemment qui va là aussi beaucoup
occuper le futur président bon
je reviens sur question d'accessibilité
qui ont été posées par plusieurs d'entre
vous bon qui est un très ancien sujet
vous le connaissez quelqu'un l'a dit on
est à peu près au clair sur toutes les
lignes de bus de RER
évidemment les nouvelles lignes je pense
à la 14 je pense aux lignes du Grand
Paris Express que nous évoquions tout à
l'heure
seront totalement accessibles et donc il
y a la question du métro historique
déjà n'est ce pas nous avions nourri
l'ambition
lorsque j'étais délégué interministériel
aux Jeux olympiques et paralympiques que
la survenue et l'organisation de cet
événement soit l'occasion de progresser
un peu de mémoire je me trouve à jour de
la RATP c'était la ligne 6 et qui avait
été choisi
aérienne en tout cas en partie de son
trajet pour être le laboratoire de
de ce que le métro historique soit
concerné pardon en réalité il y a des
deux je parle approfondir ici mais il y
a d'abord un problème financier
considérable ça coûte très cher mais
enfin ça moi qui dit qu'il faut investir
mais il y a quand même une question
d'investissement et le le deuxième sujet
il y a aussi des questions que je suis
pas si elles ont été réglées depuis mais
par exemple
les autorités de l'État notamment la
brigade de se faire pompiers de Paris
exigeait
que vous ne pouviez pas qu'il était
impossible de mettre un accessibilité
une station ou deux c'était toute la
ligne j'avais observé comme il y avait
aussi des jeux à Marseille que pour le
métro de Marseille les exigences
n'étaient pas les mêmes bon donc là il
faut un peu je passe à du surement
progresser cette affaire mais bon en
tout cas
ce sont des décisions financières ça
renvoie tous les investissements
cela est bien d'autres qui sont devant
nous ça renvoie donc Mesdames et
Messieurs députés un sujet dont vous
aurez forcément à connaître qui sont les
capacités financières d'idfm parce que
ça c'est pas une décision de la RATP
bien sûr nous pouvons contribuer comme
sur tous les investissements sur nos
ressources propres mais ça se décide
dans le cadre du contrat qu'on fait avec
IDFM c'est un contrat ambitieux déjà en
matière d'investissement le plus
ambitieux qu'il n'y ait jamais eu bon il
est en cours on en a pas parlé mais
évidemment un des sujets du futur
président RATP sera déjà d'abord il va
falloir faire un avenant pour les JO
sauf erreur là maintenant avec IDFM et
puis il faut préparer le suivant dans
lequel ces sujets pourraient
progresser faudra peut-être pas tout
d'un coup je crois qu'il faut le faire
progressivement mais c'est un signal
fort parce que évidemment c'est le
regard qu'on porte ces personnes
handicap c'est le symbole de la société
dite inclusive et il faut absolument que
le métro historique puisque c'était
votre question à plusieurs d'entre vous
concours à la réalisation de cet
objectif
s'agissant la réforme des retraites
question qui m'a été posée bon
je ne d'abord je répète que je ne renie
rien non seulement sur ce que j'ai dit
sur ce sujet si vous permettez ce que
j'aime modestement fait il y avait déjà
eu et j'avais beaucoup négocié avec les
syndicats de la RATP à l'époque une
première réforme des régimes spéciaux
qui portaient sur les bonifications et
la disparition des bonifications c'était
à l'automne 2007
et j'étais à l'époque je le rappelle le
directeur de cabinet de Monsieur
Bertrand et nous avions discuté beaucoup
beaucoup avec tous les syndicats pas que
ceux de la RATP mais la RATP en
particulier puisque c'est le sujet bon
donc nous avions déjà fait une première
avancée sur ce sujet et il y avait bien
entendu des des discussions
sérieuses des conflits sociaux m'a fait
nous avions ensemble abouti donc je ne
c'est votre question je j'assume ce que
j'ai dit bon et bon ceci dit maintenant
là au jour d'aujourd'hui si je suis pas
RATP ma demande c'est pas moi
pardonnez-moi je suis pas comme vous je
suis parti au mois de mai je ne me suis
pas présenté à des élections
législatives je ne suis plus loin de
l'onction du suffrage universel bon
c'est à gouvernement pendant la
République à sa nationale au Sénat de
décider les contours de la forme des
retraites et en particulier celle des
régimes spéciaux puisque c'est votre
question moi ma demande
c'est évidemment d'être consulté quand
même en amont sur les modalités les
conditions de faisabilité et évidemment
quand le moment viendra je n'ai pas
d'informations à vous donner là-dessus
mais de
mener ou de concourir en tout cas on
négociation indispensable et bien je ne
doute pas que ce sera difficile mais
rassurez-vous j'ai bon mais voilà
d'apporter par construction mais c'est
vraiment le rôle ça rejoint d'ailleurs
la question précédente du président de
cette entreprise avec ces équipes qui
sont déjà très impliquées donc voilà
après cette au pouvoir public
démocratiquement désigné
constitutionnellement habilités à donner
le contenu et le top de de ce qui est ou
de ce que serait ou de ce que sera
cette réforme voilà
j'en profite aussi pour évoquer le chef
de la sécurité que je n'ai pas traité ce
matin parce que je l'ai pardonne-moi
beaucoup abordé hier après-midi au Sénat
pour vous dire que
c'est un sujet essentiel plusieurs l'ont
dit aussi d'ailleurs il y a pas que vous
c'est un sujet essentiel
pas simple sur lequel il nous faut faire
des efforts j'ai indiqué hier devant vos
collègues sénateurs que l'une des
premières visites que je ferai sera au
centre de coordination opérationnelle
qui a été ouvert au mois de juillet
dernier sous l'égide du préfet de police
je me déplacerai très vite même si j'ai
l'habitude d'y aller mais pas avec la
casquette de président de la RATP si
vous voulez bien me la donner dans les
stations du nord-est de Paris parce que
c'est là qu'on voit bon en réalité vous
le savez il y a un groupement interne à
la RATP dédié à la sécurité qui comme je
l'ai indiqué à il y a pas que les
chauffeurs de bus pour lesquels on a un
problème de recrutement a aussi des
problèmes de recrutement donc ça veut
dire que les effectifs budgétaires comme
en direct classiquement ne sont pas tous
pourvus
IDFM nous a dit je crois qu'il faudrait
arriver à un millier de ces agents je
crois qu'à la fin de l'année 2022 la fin
d'un an sera plutôt autour de 900 20
donc il faut à tout prix là aussi jusque
avec eux pardon pour voir quels sont les
obstacles je vois à peu près mais pour
essayer de d'abord connaître les moyens
et puis vous le savez il y a aussi des
questions de coordination avec
à la police nationale avec j'ai vu que
la région voulait elle-même créer un
dispositif de de sécurité bon je n'ai
pas de commentaires le seul voilà
plus on est mieux c'est a priori mais à
condition que tout ça soit quand même
bien articulé dans là aussi la finalité
c'est l'efficacité mais j'ai
parfaitement conscience pour de
multiples raisons qu'il y a évidemment
un problème de sécurité et dans les
enjeux de quotidienneté la question de
sécurité évidemment est un des éléments
majeurs à prendre en considération
pour
poser la question je crois que c'est
même gaieté bon
je peux pas répondre à tout puisque bon
de toute façon elle m'a dit que son
opinion était déjà faite à la limite
quelle que soit les réponses que je fais
bon mais quand même sur le sur le RER B
juste parce que je crois que vous avez
raison là aussi on voit bien que je vous
le dis parce que vous allez avoir à
reconnaître de tout ça par encore une
fois les décisions qui devront être
prises pour le financement des
infrastructures de transport c'est
toutes les autorités organisatrices en
l'espèce ici des FM il y a un grand
programme qui est prévu pour le RER B
avec notamment le changement le
programme sur les voies des problèmes
d'exploitation et le remplacement de
toutes les rames bon ça va s'étaler dans
le temps mais c'est déjà décidé par
IDFM bon et nous allons nous opérateurs
évidemment mettre à l'oeuvre ses
décisions mais on voit bien que je le
dis parce que souvent mal connu on a
devant nous des investissements très
lourds qui posent le gros problème
d'ailleurs parce que plus vous
investissez sur les voies par exemple et
c'est absolument indispensable pour les
renouveler plus vous gêner enfin plus
vous entraîner des perturbations du
trafic et comme c'est un secret pour
personne
il y a eu des retards d'investissement
pendant plusieurs décennies on les
rattrape maintenant et il faut
poursuivre voire je le répète accroître
et ça génère je pense à partir pas
seulement mais au fait sonore de Paris
le RER B est concerné ça génère des
troubles fin des difficultés de trafic
même si les opérateurs essaient de le
faire le week-end la nuit etc mais des
difficultés trafic qui vont
supposer beaucoup de patience à part des
usagers il faut y aller il faut investir
dans les transports en commun il faut
investir dans les transports la France
est en retards la France est en retard
et l'Île-de-France en particulier mais
pas que
je vois que le président me presse
il y a pas que lui bon allez
merci monsieur le Premier ministre nous
avons donc aux questions question d'une
minute je vous propose de prendre toutes
les questions de sorte à ce que il
puisse y avoir par la suite des réponses
données durant cette commission qui est
pas de réponse écrite
j'en ai qu'une gîte pour une minute
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Premier Ministre l'amélioration de la
qualité de l'air à l'intérieur des
enceintes ferroviaires souterraines
constitue un enjeu du plan national
santé environnement qui a été adopté à
quelques mois selon l'ancêtre depuis le
début des années 2000 des mesures ont
mis en évidence dans les ancêtres
ferroviaires tels que celles du métro
parisien des concentrations en
particulier fines en suspension dans
l'air les PM de 5 PM10 qui sont en
moyenne trois fois plus élevés que dans
l'air extérieur urbain alors face à
cette situation question est simple
c'est quelle démarche volontariste
souhaitez-vous engager pour améliorer la
qualité de l'air donc dans le réseau
souterrain de la de la RATP pour
préserver la santé respiratoire à la
fois des usagers mais aussi de vos
futurs collaborateurs et puisqu'il me
reste quelques secondes et un petit peu
à l'aparté puisque vous avez évoqué la
question la Coupe du monde de rugby
j'espère que si vous prenez la tête de
la RATP l'Artp pour annoncement
accompagner les 15 de France vers la
victoire mais surtout faire du mécénat
sportif en direction de
du rugby et puis particulièrement
peut-être pour le 15 parlementaire merci
merci chers collègues
la parole est à Daniel brulbois
monsieur le Premier ministre je
souhaiterais vous rassurer nous sommes
persuadés que vous êtes à la hauteur et
que votre image est une chance pour la
RATP enfin c'est ce que nous pensons
très fort dans le Jura Monsieur le
Premier Ministre moi je voudrais vous
demander alors que la balance extérieure
du commerce extérieur de la France est
un sujet et que la RATP est vraiment une
vitrine à l'international de la France
qu'est-ce que vous pensez pouvoir
trouver de nouveaux contrats et on a
toujours à l'esprit la réussite des
contrats avec l'Arabie Saoudite ou le
Qatar avec le métro automatique ou
encore avec les États-Unis et comment
pensez-vous développer cela pour notre
pays c'est le premier ministre soin de
répondre bon alors je vais essayer
d'aller rapidement
d'abord des questions liées à la
transition écologique au développement
durable la première c'était sur la
qualité de l'air bon c'est un vrai sujet
là aussi vous avez trouvé j'essaie
d'être cohérent voyez comme la question
des investissements il répond
on va je vous disais tout à l'heure
IDFM remplacé plus de la moitié dans les
années à venir du matériel roulant à la
RATP par du réseau métro là
dans les matériaux dans les voitures qui
ont été commandées qui vont être livrées
l'émission des particules qui se produit
à l'occasion du freinage
va être diminué je crois de 10 ou 15%
ce qui aura un impact
fondamental important en tout cas sur la
qualité de l'air bon la difficulté qu'on
a c'est un sujet je vous le dis
prioritaire pour IDFM je le répète aussi
et évidemment pour pour la RATP le sujet
vous le savez c'est que il existe pas de
normes sur les particules dans
l'environnement intérieur ça veut dire
est-ce que vous est-ce que c'est bien
pas bien ou quels sont vos objectifs à
partir du moment où je peux pas il est
évident que c'est pas la RATP même qui
va faire son référentiel serait jugé
partie ça n'aurait pas de sens bon
raison pour laquelle les services de
l'État en saisit en ces
d'accord que cet agence a rendu c'est
récent en juin dernier
c'est son avis sur les résultats de son
expertise sur la qualité de l'air
précisément dans les enceintes
souterraines ferroviaires et elle a dit
en l'état des connaissances
scientifiques actuelles on ne peut pas
conclure sur des effets défavorables sur
la santé des voyageurs et à l'issue de
cette audition les députés ont voté pour
la nomination de Jean Castex tout comme
les sénateurs Jean Castex qui a donc
pris la tête de la RATP un système cette
séance on se retrouve très bientôt pour
revoir un autre moment parlementaire